pourtant écrit maintenant l'âge moyen de cette
52e législature est de 49 ans ok
boomer ok boomer ok
[Musique]
nous sommes responsables et nous devons être
responsables m.  orateur combien de
dirigeants mondiaux pendant combien de décennies ont vu
et su ce qui s'en vient mais ont
décidé qu'il était politiquement plus
opportun de le garder à huis clos
ma génération et les générations après
moi n'ont pas ce luxe en l'an
2050 je serai  56 ans mais en ce
moment l'âge moyen de cette 52e
législature est de 49 ans d'accord boomer
[Musique]
les institutions politiques actuelles se sont
révélées incompétentes pour
penser à l'extérieur à court
terme le changement politique est si rigidement sacrifié pour le
pouvoir les slogans sont faciles  mais ce genre de choses
cette action est difficile l'
action climatique ne peut plus être sacrifiée
pour des convenances politiques le
changement climatique est une vérité profondément gênante
[Musique]
vous